[Music]
once upon a time the world was great and
there were dragons crags and larch trees
nothing changed nothing progressed and
nothing died it was a pretty boring
place living below the Dragons were a
race of humanoids who were to become
Giants one day for no apparent reason
fire was born in this created disparity
heat and cold light and dark life and
death the flame contained the four Lord
Souls the souls of death life light and
dark went to Neto the witch of izalith
Gwyn and the pygmy respectively with
this new power the Giants waged a war
against the Dragons they would have lost
but a scaleless dragon betrayed his
brethren and the lords prevailed NATO
went and children his tomb the witch
built her crib in the city of izalith
Gwyn built his home close to the Sun and
the pygmy remained underground waiting
hiding the pygmy smaller and quieter
than the Giants fathered the human race
while Gwyn started an age of fire built
around the first flame fast forward
thousands of years and the world has
gone to [ __ ] the flame is fading and
Gwyn is afraid of the dark so he
sacrifices himself and becomes human
night light this is where you come in
the world needs a new leader only the
most powerful soul will be able to
overcome the terrors of Lord run and
kill Gwyn if you can you will either
Kindle the first flame with your own
soul or let the flame fade and turn the
world over to dark but remember both
options are put forward by primordial
serpents who are imperfect dragons and
liars
so which choice is the right one